[Music]
in Disney star demise news what that's a
lot of dissing star like a lazy Lohan
did you see her dancing oh my god she's
coked out for sure she was shooting a
reality show - are you serious
she opened up a new nightclub in Mykonos
[Music]
yeah those are dancing oh you thought it
no I think I want is she still dating
that super stupid rich Korean guy what
they really Danny I don't think the
rumors really were dating who else is
like [ __ ] up after the Disney about to
find out her submitted by Power Rangers
Go Go Power Rangers and eater a former
that's or even actor Orlando Brown was
arrested for burglary in Las Vegas
he's been [ __ ] up dude he's so [ __ ]
up why is he so [ __ ] up like this - OH
burglary in Las Vegas
well are you Raven you know I thought he
was funny other Raven hey you actually
my favorite on the day I met her on
person once and he was [ __ ] took them to
like it was hella high just Charlie yeah
he was I remember I saw him in a gas
station and I was like hey you're a
Lendl Brown right and then I forgot his
response but just I remember leaving
that situation thinking damn this guy is
[ __ ] drugged out there's so many
videos of him just [ __ ] up just trying
to bite his ear I don't remember his
words but the way he was speaking it was
like he was like tweaked out or
something here just talking really weird
but anyway this dude he's in the news
again because he got arrested again
Disney should have like a like a
veteran's program the DEA to help them
like cope with life yeah the Disney a
fan they should have like a team of
counselors like okay and it's Mickey
Mouse and [ __ ] Mickey Mouse comes out
he's like oh car doors oh you know
you're not gonna be famous not much
anymore and you know life is gonna be
different
oh no like did you have something like
that and they said yeah because this guy
definitely needs it so he was recently
arrested because he broke into
friends restaurant and claim that he was
there with permission to change the
locks
certified locksmith por am the owners
like what the hell annoyed did it and so
he was he ended up pressing charges and
the friend said that he felt it was
necessary to press charges so this dude
can finally get them dude ah be [ __ ]
hilarious if he's in there with a ski
mask and a flashlight and like a crowbar
and he's like yeah I do this all the
time I'm gonna show you the video I was
thinking like he's all covered up and
he's still for some reason still wearing
and that's a raven t-shirt he got her
face tattooed on his neck and chest yeah
raven symone what oh sure why I don't
know I mean that's what the report might
sorry that's good that's like that's
like a gang you know like that's that's
what got him oh my god are you double
engaged before we got engaged
was that a promise ring yeah no it's
more like I was like can I have your
virginity drink
oh no it's [ __ ] she really wanted me in
bigger a girl ring that's a u-turn
that's funny
cuz she said I really want it ring and
he was like oh that's your virginity
ring because it's like I give you this
ring for your virginity first week it
and then we [ __ ] is your fiance Korean
too he's Chinese Shanee whoa well the
nicest teeth in the world
yeah with ten balls cigarette stands
between his teeth
he's Shanghainese though that's their
friend oh is that fancy if it was Kwan's
out you know what I mean there's like
parts of mainland where it's cultured
still but there's other part that's the
part that Pete and cups and [ __ ] so
which ones are cultured Shanghai's one
of them people from Beijing or another
one
well they don't even consider themselves
Chinese but they are do the British I
mean there's like a billion provinces is
like naming 50 states
so Guangzhou is the one that people are
painting come on so I'm just joking
that's uh the biggest County that's like
the Texas but they're not that do not
not copy I want to see where the copy
use come from I know right like the
Alabama of China I'm gonna show you guys
we blow that what's the Alabama of China
there's another mainland Chinese that I
like oh my god but what's the Florida of
China all right here we go
hi [ __ ] my sister you know there's a
place in Las Vegas by the way I suppose
I'm to crash through the wall the
ceiling the cracks on the wall and the
ceiling I was expecting to fall through
the wall with those other security
camera videos no yeah what is he looking
for money
crack food he's doing nothing he's like
but then he getting he ended up taking a
ketchup ketchup
what was that he just picked something
out I don't know he took a napkin got a
rag for fingerprints no for this to joy
over the camera it's like he spent a
good five minutes already and he finally
decides to cover the camera yeah he
looks at the camera in five minutes
versus Eva's camera I'm sorry do you
think that's easier to spot it out
because if you're going through like
security footage of scene the emptiness
all of a sudden you see it covered then
you're like well let me go so this is my
shot Jesus why is he so happy that's the
happiest mug shot I've seen being known
as a happy mug shot taker because in
January he went viral for this he has
good spirit he said a good TiVo mom so
he looks like he's having a blast I
think he's on Matty the thing about him
is that he is clothing isn't all [ __ ]
up and raggedy he's somehow has so got
money somehow this is the Raven I don't
even know like I want to go to that
artist that's one of the worst tattoos
I've ever seen that [ __ ] looks like
Roseanne you think he did it himself
what if that's his kids no they're
saying that that's Raven Raven I'll show
you a photo of his inspiration oh my
oh man poor guy I wonder one i wonder
how and when he started to fall off like
that that of all photos what happens to
people like I want to know like I want
to I want to maybe he was molested by a
lot of the Disney exactly stuff you know
I heard that that [ __ ] happens in
Hollywood though like like there's like
a weird petal ring in Hollywood that
like cuz there was that one kid yeah I'm
sorry
Cory felt Feldman right yeah and and he
he says that he was a part of this like
underground pedal thing and like his
managers would just send them off to get
done up by other agents and just weird
[ __ ] went down I mean how far like we
just had this like hashtag me to thing
right where it's like all these
producers are doing it but that's
expected like in any place of power you
expect that kind of [ __ ] to go down but
this is next-level though they [ __ ] up
all all the kids man he was a young
little boy you probably got you know 30
now oh you know whoa oh this guy this
guy yeah that's who you knew I was
talking about right Orlando oh wow I
didn't really seem so young stove oh my
gosh I want to ask them all like what
happened what do you think it has to do
it did any of you guys peak in high
school Pete thank God no like what do
you mean like that was like you are job
by city everybody was like huh
you hit your career like don't you think
people who peak in high school it's just
I was gonna break a deaf in high school
no it's different all the girls look
like they're 25 years old in high school
now that's cute everyone knows how to
dress nice need a makeup nice like weird
like I remember my classmates looking
like clowns and yeah like girls were
putting on makeup ridiculous I shouldn't
at the fingertips
they blend better than I do now yeah I
don't even try go to school with contour
that's a lot of work I mean he's been
arrested so many times like for drug
possession for a domestic violence case
justing arrests all this crap poor guy
damn he's gone how many other Disney
stars got [ __ ] up I think JT is the
only one right that's kind of not
[ __ ] Oh Selena Gomez's fine oh well
[ __ ] Disney star Lizzie McGuire seems
like one day is Ariana Grande Disney she
what no Nicola Nickelodeon Nickelodeon
but like how about a Miley Cyrus she got
she got crazy
I want remember yeah she's alright have
you done the fun of her the little
sister or whatever and her boyfriend
that's by far the most unattractive
couple ever you gotta find it look up
Noah Cyrus and and she's dating that one
of those little whatever colorful the
[ __ ] wrappers will then by far everyone
little these days I don't know big papa
a big people it's gonna be next medium
great all the sizes are taken excels
enlarges gun yeah give me a better
picture he looks like he's got moist
anger there's a boys all those kind of
people I see the buff the photo right
above and he's kissing her face oh my
god is that what they broke up that's a
cell phone ringing that's the sounds
that face makes I've seen yeah I've seen
him before though why does he think he
looks like he's do well he's one of
those little stupid whatever rappers yes
I'll have shitty tattoos like they all
go to the same guy in the same garage
and just tattoo their faces up that's
almost like he smells like the
McDonald's ball pens
here a photo oh but I feel Eugenia that
boy looks like he smells like weed and
flamin hot cheetos and sweat what
happened with the whole notion of life
you should never get a face tattoo
because the worst mistake of your life I
don't know man is popular now rappers
are just [ __ ] who I feel like you
know when tattoos lost its edge you
gotta like now edge the edge right so
face tattoos are like the next level of
like oh [ __ ] I got a tattoo but I'd
never get one on my face so you got to
always keep like going crazier and
crazier first it was the neck and not
people everyone get so now you have to
move to the thing well why do all their
tattoos like every single one of those
referees are face tattoos looks so
terrible like none of them are we nicely
done well cuz they're not done by nice
already it's like infected needles and
[ __ ] I thought that was like a meaning
behind like if you murder someone you
get a favorite murder [ __ ] they the
[ __ ] grew up in the suburbs like it
had a meaning but now it's just like
four games before back then they did
yours but not anymore
oh no how they feel now like the
gangster like the oh jeez that have face
tattoos and actually met something yeah
like I wonder how they feel about these
little kids getting they probably look
at him go mmm can't wait to butyrate
these yep that's exactly what I think
they you know I can't wait for you
badasses to come to jail their tattoos
look like when you get those temporary
tattoos from class when you're a kid and
just slap it on everywhere from a cereal
box ya know for morphing only just
everywhere just slap it everywhere
[Music]